[Applause]
Chekhov Rico requesting attack chopper
class telling team unclear to the point
[Music]
[Applause]
black ops 4 is the game that lets you
play with your friends in more ways than
ever before and we all love black ops 4
that combat experience but imagine if we
take that experience you know and love
and we spin it on its head and we drop
you into a large massive world where you
have to survive to be the last man
standing
assist pause here for a minute I don't
have to describe to you how Battle
Royale works these games are no secret
we play them too but for us to even
consider this kind of experience it had
to be unique and done in a way only
black ops could do now we are doing this
but we are doing it the black ops way a
survival game with the best most refined
mechanics in the world
our signature controls and gameplay
systems and the kind of fast-paced
action that only Call of Duty can
deliver all in the biggest map that
we've ever made over 1,500 times bigger
than nuke town and this is just the
beginning we're bringing to bear ten
years worth of black ops universe
features that's your favorite characters
your favorite weapons and the most
iconic parts of your favorite Maps and
we're putting them all in one place a
crazy collision of fun and then we're
going to let you navigate that world
with land sea and air vehicles
this is something that you have not
experienced before
let's keep it rolling do you remember
your CIA handler Hudson or maybe you
remember that very first very sweet rcxd
kill the numbers Mason what do they mean
or that time that when you partnered up
with Rezanov for revenge
and which of these multiple endings did
you experience with the Menendez or how
about that one time when you work with
your friend Woods to take the hind now I
should probably mention this one to your
favorite zombies casts weapons and gear
- this is something totally new
this is doing battle rial the blackops
way this is blackout
[Applause]
[Music]